so you know at some point in this
tournament you were a minus two is that
correct that's correct and somehow
you're now at 50 after playing two
really great games today's game was so
dominating uh there was a point in the
game where you sacrificed your knight
take us to that point because that was
the first thrilling moment of the game
so first of all it feels good to be back
to 50 percent and
yeah i was really proud of that moment
so when i sacrificed the piece
i've i was like if i don't do this maybe
i'll get like a worse position so i
thought oh it was before this it was
yeah yeah it was um
so here after
after b4
i thought if i play knight c4 here
she's going to trade and bishop a4
and i kept calculating and it felt like
i will be losing a pawn or having a
slighter specific queen c7 yeah
and then i'm pinned so she can maybe go
queenie too i thought and
seemed unclear so i thought okay i'm
going to spice up the things
and uh sacrifice the piece and once it
takes d5 and i'm getting three pawns if
she takes the 1985
um i'll capture in e4 first and
knight g5 would be nice but it doesn't
work because the knight is trapped so
yeah knight knight d2 is the only move
and then i thought
um no i thought to take the pawn in a5
if she goes there because there's knight
b3 to protect it i mean i wanted to make
sure i have the three pawns and then
well d5 looked mighty good to us as well
yeah d5 d4
so i felt pretty comfortable i thought i
have you know enough for the piece
and
after that i think the position i
equalized um
but her pawn in d5 will be weaker than
mine in c4 i think
it's easier to attack
so
i think maybe here this knight h2 i
don't think it was a good move for her
it seems like the
engine is not saying anything about it
but i thought maybe rookie four is
interesting
um
yeah i don't know why she moved tonight
because moving i mean keeping the knight
in f3 i will need to play you know
bishop g7 h6 to be to
eventually play a five
but going with the knight back i thought
this just she just let me push the pawns
and
um step by step i just got a better
position she could play bishop c6 right
bishop says six
yes that's the idea that's the idea yeah
yeah so wait wait wait after rookie four
i was not gonna play bishop g7 yet i
forgot about that
uh rook c8 i think i was planning to go
and then if you go bishop c6 i take and
um
rook takes c4
and queen b6 and i think
or b7 somewhere and then the trades
happen and the game continues yeah but
her night h2 didn't give her this chance
at all i thought it was not a good idea
for her because it wasn't clear to me
why why she played it and after that it
was easy for me to march the pawn so i
felt comfortable well you got a paw
information that i don't think any of us
have seen
recently are or ever
i know i i was really impressed by this
maneuver here bringing your rook up and
then rook back
and then eventually you got this
dominant position when you took the pawn
on d5
uh yes i was i was trying to attract her
to play b5 and then yes just uh you know
going for the pawns and then slowly push
them i was a little bit nervous when i
actually played the
play d5 d4 um
yeah that was like oh
wow and then the ending is beautiful i
think but yeah i was calculating this
line and
maybe she can try last move knight f2
instead of knight b2 because
i have to take it and then c7 but i can
stop that pawn with bishop e6
it's not a problem just yeah
exactly
with d2 on the way great comeback how
did you
write yourself to make this come back so
far did you do anything special after
those two losses
um
not really actually i've decided that
i'll try to be relaxed a little bit i'm
actually streaming i started streaming
on twitch so i'm streaming each day
after
no matter what i do just one day i was
very sad and i didn't scream but
you know i'm
i'm just
feeling relaxed and i have the support
of you know the people who are following
me on twitch that's what i was going to
say yeah how have they been talking to
you through this tournament um it's been
really nice i'm super i'm super excited
to to be a part of the twitch community
and there are a couple of people who've
you know they kept saying it's okay so
now i played a great game keep going and
i mean i usually don't get don't get to
look on social media when i'm when i'm
playing but this time
it's different because i kind of got
used to
doing stuff online a little bit more so
feels good all right we're gonna give
you a chance to go join your fans on
social media congrats on your victory
thank you so much first of all obviously
i've enjoyed uh
i'm lurking on your show and sometimes
i've chatted with you a little bit but i
like it when your cat you know like
you know video bombs you it gets it your
way it is like leave me alone
nicely done today and good luck keep up
the good work thank you all right cheers